Chris how you doing buddy oh what's up
rich 19 and lost uh yeah so I'm I'm 19
right now first I want to say thank you
for everything you do yeah I read I read
your book when I was like uh 17 I'm like
a senior in high school so it really
helped out a lot I got in shape and
started boxing good so I want to say
thanks for that but so what do you lost
on still well it's
just like I guess
like like like LifeWise and career-wise
um you know after after high school I
kind of decid not to go to college and
just go into uh Landscaping okay start
working Landscaping but I've been doing
that for like a year or two
and um I just kind of been looking at
different things
but I'm just still like like just
wandering around in a desert you know
kind of feels like what I'm doing right
now just let me let me uh I I don't let
me phrase it to you in a different type
of question I can produce a magic wand
and wave it and solve your problem what
does that look like for
you
um I just wanted some you know like
advice
on
uh like how to make
money um career wise like what what kind
of money so let's so let's define money
what kind of money are we talking about
uh the the most money I can make Like
You Want To Make It Rain money yeah
talking like Fu money yeah Fu money okay
well yeah what are the um what are the
six ways that you can make serious
amounts of money I've covered this many
times you know what they
are yeah I know you said CEO uh top
level sales M entrepreneurship the most
the biggest one yeah and you know
I I uh like I I've tried you know you
know side businesses through Landscaping
like I once you know saved up like like
$5,000 and you know bought bought some
tools hired some hired some guys I knew
and you know wrote up some proposals and
you think that that's G the level of
wealth that you're looking for no so why
you wasting your time doing
it like I just
don't again it's just like wandering
wandering in a desert trying trying
stuff out well I mean here's the thing
you're you're you're figuring out ways
on what not to do at this stage yeah
yeah okay so you're figuring out
Landscaping is not going to make you
wealthy you're figuring out getting
tools and hiring guys in landscaping
isn't going to make you wealthy it's not
that you can't make you know money doing
trade work there's um so there's a guy
by the name of Noah Kagan um you know we
did some private conversations few years
ago we were part of this like YouTube
group and he was like um you know I want
to blow up my channel and really get
some reach and have some interesting
conversations and he's an entrepreneur
right so he kind of pivoted his
production to telling like success
stories so here's a bit of advice go
follow Noah Kagan on YouTube there's a
recent video that he put out the last
couple weeks where he saw a guy that's
in trades that makes $600 million a year
renovating basements he has a large
business with salespeople with
contractors with inventory with patents
on uh you know products and items that
solve problems success leaves Clues
right so if where you're at right now is
working with your hands it's cool no
problem you know I did a lot of that
when I was in my high school years in my
early 20s you know I planted Christmas
trees I worked at a mechanic shop uh
mostly doing a lot of break jobs and
tuneups and whatever they would bring in
for you know like just any kind of
regular
handiwork um I worked for the ministry
of Natural Resources cleared out Portage
Trails built things I've done a lot of
[__] with my hands but then I realized
that like you're going to get really
[__] tired really fast and at some
point people that that work with their
hands their entire lives their hands
turn into like baseball gloves right
like the fingers turn into sausages
their hands can barely move they get
arthritis they're always tired it's not
it's not the easiest way to make serious
amounts of money sure you can make
yourself you know wealthy but the
easiest way to make serious money is you
either have to you know compound money
so money will make money this is what my
mom used to say she say money will make
you money or people will make you money
meaning you have to have a business or
you have to have a lot of money you have
to know know how to invest it I mean you
could start with a business component
make a lot of money then start to invest
it and then diversify and do other
things with it but what you're learning
right now is what doesn't work right
right so now you know that you can't be
trading time for money because that's
what you're doing right like what's your
hourly wage uh it's like 26 how many
hours are in a day just eight no 24 24
how many hours the day do you work just
eight that's it right so you've you've
got a limited earning potential what's
the definition of
stupidity um I doing doing the same
thing over over again
expecting doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
right that's Insanity though right
that's that's what you're doing
stupidity Insanity whatever you want to
call it I call it stupidity right it's
not going to get you know get you what
you want when you're working can you
have earphones in no you're not allowed
to have anything you know that you're
able to listen to no because I mean just
for safety reasons okay do you drive to
and from the work site yeah how long
does that commute back and forth uh 10
minutes what do you what do you
typically do with that
time just listen to music try try to
wake up okay what do you usually do with
your lunch how long's your lunch uh just
30 minutes how long 30 yeah what do you
do with that time just know eat talk to
the guys okay so you got 30 minutes to
eat you got 10 minutes there at work 10
minutes back what does that get you to
50 minutes right 50 minutes okay you
should be using that time to listen to
podcast listen to an audio book do
something productive to teach you a new
skill that exite you to open up your
eyes to something new okay right you
want to make [__] you money you're gonna
have to take some [__] you approach to
your life right right you want to make
real money some real impact you're going
to have to figure out you know some way
to solve some big problems you know you
you make real money when you solve
really big problems right like so as an
example like one of the things that sort
of cued me to do this Q&A tonight I got
an email from um I vid IQ or one of
these you know service providers that I
subscribed to and they said hey
congratulations your unplugged Alpha
channel did 4 million views you know way
to
go okay cool four million views that's
awesome what about four billion views
right like I like I'm looking forward to
getting reach you know in these areas I
mean if you guys want to help me out
make sure you subscribe make sure you
comment you do all that [__] for the
algorithm and share stuff with people
that will find you know stuff like this
useful but it's it's pivoting your life
Chris right you take a intentional
approach to everything that you do right
okay we all die we all have something
very very common we're all going to be
dead we're all gonna be cold and we're
all gonna be six feet under at some
point you've got more Runway ahead of
you than I do right okay but you still
have loads and loads of time the problem
that 19 year olds and and 20-some year
old guys make is they spend too much
time [__] around thinking they've got
loads and loads of time to figure
everything out and you know before you
know it and as you get older by the way
Chris time moves you know seems to move
faster like when you're in your teen
years it's like time seems to move slow
when you're 20s it still seems to move
really slow until you hit 30 then for
some strange reason your 30s and your
40s and as you move you know into your
Autumn years of your life move very very
quickly and you know before you know it
you're going to be like my kids are
grown up uh all my friends are either
sick or dying or out of shape what have
I done with myself right so take take
your life very very
serious get out there and look for ways
to solve problems I mean look the ways
that you make money again are seet jobs
you know CEO CFO CTO licensed
professionals doctors surgeons lawyers
eye doctors uh Financial instrument
Brokers you know money managers stuff
like that people that command an
audience actors musicians athletes
influencers YouTubers whatever you want
to call them high-end sales right rather
than selling a shitty old car sell a
expensive brand new G50 the uh Jet right
or whatever they are the G55 whatever it
happens to be science technology
engineering maths right I know Facebook
programmers that make $800,000 a year if
that's not your thing you don't want to
sit sit in front of a computer and be
surrounded by Ray bones prouns and and
Geeks and stuff like that okay move on
to the next thing entrepreneurship so if
if you were 19 again what what would you
do if you were I would be 19y old if you
were well I mean like what would you do
first of all I can tell how serious you
are about solving this problem by what
you do with your
time I can tell how serious anybody is
with what they do with their [__]
time right so if it's like I get up eat
breakfast commute to work listen to some
music do my job talk to some people at
work you know dur during breaks and
lunches listen to music driving home
right there you telling me that you're
not doing something more productive with
a commute time or your spare time and
you're not working like listening to a
podcast listen to a business podcast
listen to a business Business book you
should have an audible subscription it's
like 10 bucks a month or something like
that and get a new book every month on
something that you're very interested in
that will make you
money okay all right thank you Rich see
what I'm saying yeah I understand I'm do
that sure use my my time more wisely
thank you well raise your
standards all right when you start
raising your standards you know when it
comes to women that you're going to deal
with and what you're going to do for a
living and how you're going to earn your
money and where you're going to live and
the kind of car you drive all of these
things raise your standards in all areas
of your life and hold yourself to those
higher standards surround yourself with
excellence and good people good men that
are good at being men get rid of losers
stay away from loser women raising your
standards is the most important thing
that you can do to increase your
opportunities in life okay raising your
standards simple concept might sound
very easy or too stupid to be you know
worth worth doing anything with but
trust you raise your standards in every
area of life it's just one step up The
Next Step Up The Next Step Up The Next
Step Up The Next Step and you keep
moving you know as long as you're moving
upwards you're either growing or dying
in life right so right now what are you
doing you growing or you're dying I mean
I feel like I'm growing you know how
you're not even using your spare time to
learn anything new I mean well after
after work you know I I box I work out
regularly
good um you know
I I enjoy I enjoy philosophy I enjoy you
know reading reading things about
business I mean i' I've read a lot of
these books like the everything
everything store by Jeff Bas it was
pretty good I I read that yeah but
you're not acting on it though I know so
I I got to start I I think that's the
problem I just got to start acting on it
and start how do you how do you eat an
elephant one bite at a time you know I I
you know on this story so I um I did
this Retreat up at Blue Mountain in
Callingwood uh 105 years ago and we had
a guy that was a member of our business
for him that ran this daycare center and
he came from the Cayman Islands um you
know he was an accounting guy uh there
was a hurricane I can't remember what
year it was it was in the early 2000s
but it it flattened the [__] Island
just flattened the place and he was like
I you know I can't go back I got to do
something different and he lost his [__]
and he went from being a bean counting
you know accountant you know looking at
ways to get people to Offshore money and
you know stuff like this and he said I
just started climbing mountains and he
summited all Seven Peaks on every
continent every single continent he
climbed the highest mountain okay so at
Blue Mountain up in Collingwood he's
part of our business Forum he runs some
very successful daycare centers at this
time he did this years ago we all knew
what his background story was and you
know we walked to the base of the
mountain and you know we all kind of
looked around and we looked at our go-to
guy because he was the guy that climbed
the seven Continental Peaks you know
including Mount Everest and we said what
is the best way to get to the top of
this mountain and he just looked us all
and he said one step at a time you just
move one foot in front of the other and
you start making some progress and
you'll you'll be at the top you know
before you know
it so in your life it's one step at a
time as long as long as you're heading
in the right direction you're heading
up then you're doing the right thing
when you find yourself in a situation
that you're not heading up you're going
in the wrong direction I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out